Hello, and welcome to my new set!
I'm on a chaise lounge!
I'm on a chair!
Chaise lounge!
Wingback!
Chaise!
Chair!
Both at the same time!
I also got a new jacket; it was formerly owned
by Roger - he had it embroidered with his
name - but one thing here is not new: my brain.
Because unlike the vast majority of cells
in my body, the neurons I had when I was an
infant are the neurons that I have right now.
They will be the same neurons I have when
I die.
Our brains are us.
They do not replace.
It's all part of the magical mystery that
is our minds.
Now, some - okay, me, occasionally - argue
that psychology is a softer science than chemistry
or biology or physics.
Well, frankly, that's true: there's more discussion
of tendencies, of maybes, the allowances for
statistical significance are wider, and you
want to know why?
Because it's more complicated.
Your brain is more complicated than anything
taught in theoretical physics classes.
There are no equations that can define it.
Though it operates within the same laws as
the rest of the cosmos, its complexity rivals
that of the entire rest of the universe combined!
Excluding all the other brains, of course.
You'd think that we'd be really good at understanding
brains, though, since, you know, we all have
one and use one all the time.
We experience the world as a brain connected
to sensing systems, and yet, as we will see,
our insights about how brains work are often
very wrong!
So just throw out everything you think you
know!
And that is why we have this wonderful science
of psychology.
Though you cannot, as early psychologists
wished, break the human psyche into "atoms
of consciousness", through careful study of
your mind, you can, at least in part, understand
your mind!
And the minds of others!
We can heal the sick, deepen understanding,
and improve functions.
That's really the heart of it.
Minds trying to understand minds.
The reason we do things, why we think and
feel the way we do.
The schools of thought, the techniques, the
history, the characters, from Freud to advanced
neuroscience - from healthy to broken, from
everyday behaviors to the deepest depths of
your subconscious.
And also, did I mention?
Chaise lounge!
Why don't I have a cigar?
I should have a cigar.
I honestly do not have any idea how to acquire
a cigar; Freud would be so disappointed in
me!
Actually, did you know that Freud was, in
addition to cigars, also addicted to cocaine?
One of the many things you will learn here
in Crash Course Psychology!